if you asked Browns fans at this point
at this very point last year many of
whom as you know if there was a Venn
diagram remember those back in the days
where it's one circle here and then
another circle there and at what point
the two circles mesh okay is the spot
where there's a common area so a few one
circle was Browns fans in another circle
fans of the Ohio State University
football that Venn diagram in many ways
could be pretty close to two circles
completely enveloping each other right
that's how much of a common area there
is I would say so asking that Browns fan
base in that Venn diagram meshed area
what they thought of Baker Mayfield at
this time last year I dare say there
might be a few unmentionable words said
in that man's direction based on him
planting the Oklahoma flag on the Ohio
State turf in the middle of the
horseshoe right correct so a man who
definitely knows how much a fan base can
go from hating you because of your
college affiliation to loving you in the
Cleveland Ohio area is on the phone line
none other than Cleveland Browns
defender Jabril Peppers how are you
Jabril hey don't did I get that accurate
correct nah nah no but you don't think
that Browns fans are you think that some
are conflicted about rooting for you
when you put all what are you here give
me an example
the Browns fans who don't care where I
went to school that but you know the
just like Michigan's fan base is so
diehard and and you know always
supportive of their unit you know I
guess Ohio stays like that as well
hold on a second hold on a second I'm
gonna scare you okay I'm gonna scare you
to try and get the hiccups away you
ready you ready you ready did that scare
you breathe out of a paper bag or
something all right yeah
I don't know bro pepper seeds best you
can
can you describe what it was like when
Baker Mayfield went in the game one week
ago tonight
oh man you could just you know but bake
bake bake is shown in practice that you
know he's been preparing you know in
this league you know it's always one
play away so you always got to stay
ready they guys did a great job of that
he came in the game until he was
supposed to do man so so when he's done
oh you come in the time again and that's
be a game ball so was there a palpable
lift on the sidelines because I could
feel it through the television set
[Music]
definitely man and you know we just all
wanted to just rally together Matt cuz I
know a lot of people counted us out but
you know we've been down before we're no
stranger to that and we know how to claw
fight our way better and I think I think
we definitely did a great job with that
as well
Jabril peppers here on the Rich Eisen
show what's he what's it been like in
practice
so far this week man we have a tough
pass going out there at six hours away
playing in the Bay Area on a baseball
field so you know we meant getting our
minds right for the you know Oakland
Raiders get ready for Marshawn Markkula
you know Jerry cook Derek Carr all those
guys and office has been doing the same
and we just trying to stack win you son
as so when you say play on a baseball
field you will be playing on the the
infield on occasional occasionally in
the home of the Oakland Athletics are
you anyway preparing for that like are
you thrown like a dirt patch out there
in practice this week to try and get
ready for that
I mean it to me the only thing that
really matters this is whether or not
you know as far as terrain when I'm
saying football um you know dirt though
that that really has no no second I
think you know you might get better
better footing in it but you know high
school myself was out there so you know
taking a trip back to Maryland
interesting so you're used to playing
that's amazing that that really is
amazing what do you think about that
Jabril peppers here on the Rich Eisen
show so on a scale of one to ten with
one being crazy and ten being totally
out of your mind crazy how crazy is Greg
Williams Jabril crazy you know it's
always a method to his madness man and
he has various tactics and techniques to
get the best out of this place most
don't understand it but when you play
for you know you you start to understand
him a little bit and you know this is my
second year being around so you know
everything he said it makes sense to me
you know is this the way he says it you
know but you know you can't listen you
can't listen to the way your coach says
just what do you okay that's been a big
takeaway for me so then what has he done
where you say you know you know what
he's trying to motivate you like how do
you how do you realize it in real time
what has he done for you
essentially it's been many things real
hard you know ten point one specific
time but um you know practice you know
he makes practice as chaotic as possible
all the yelling and screaming you know
to see how he reacts under stress you
know what I mean so when game day comes
game days is more calm and relaxed is
easier than the practice work you know
he kind of doesn't do all the yelling or
you know all the theatrics that you guys
call it um unless you know it's a a big
big bust in coverage or you know
something that you know we all know and
went over numerous times in a week but
other than that you know game there's
alright day no get us to call us as you
go and we go out and play and
obviously you being a playmaker in your
own right gibreel peppers from a scale
of one to ten one being a man ten being
a grown-ass man what about miles Garrett
sitting up there in front of your
defense Oh Massa Massa Levin man that's
that's one of the craziest week athletes
and I've been around I've been around
some nice ass athletes but you know I
tell them all the time are you too big
and strong to move that status and be
that explosive you know what I mean so
it's like you know I don't know how you
continuously block them without you know
tipping them more double chambers but if
you do that now you're giving the other
guys you had one-on-one matchups we can
also rush the past we can also blitz you
know what I mean and we understand
protections and how to beat them so you
know we we bring a lot to the table when
we go out there and Mazdas definitely
wrench that up because we know he's
gonna be in the head of our opponent
well I mean you know and I just I think
you know a lot of people are saying what
may feel did against the Jets and
obviously that was remarkable we're
forgetting about another number one
overall pick and how he changed the game
- I think Miles Garrett changed that
game when he had Arnold early on in the
first quarter I think the Jets
offensively started looking there and
saying okay it's a short week we've got
a 21 year old piece of China here that
that that there's a bull in this china
shop right now I saw that I'm wondering
what you saw absolutely you know I think
it was a lot of plays that you know
we're made that kind of changed the game
you know for me I would say the strip
bar Denzel was probably one of the you
know most game-changing clays and that
gang as far as on our defensive side of
the ball cuz that really got the
momentum rolling back got us some points
on the board and you know we kind of
never looked back from there so you know
my mom's gonna be mild you know he's
going to disrupt the pasture he's gonna
have game set in place but when you have
other guys especially rookies stepping
up like Jannard Denzel you know making
plays you got you got guys like
teammates making crucial clays Joe
Schobert is miss tell
for us in the middle so you know we we
finally put it all together then in a
year with his playbook has definitely
allowed us to play faster and really
understand what you know coach really
wants us to understand about what he's
trying to do and take away with the
officers trying to do it and now I think
heading into the black hole are you
aware of Hugh Jackson's history with
that organization is that is that been
uttered at all far this week I know I
know he coached there but that's about
you know all all of it that I know I
don't know the extensive history not
okay because you know I'm sure this is a
big one for him too in terms of Tyrod
Taylor the sensitivity of losing his job
and what he means in the locker room
still I'm wondering if you could give
some voice to that what has it been like
around there from hat perspex
how's the ultimate Pro man you know he
still recovered from you know his injury
that he suffered on Thursday night games
but Todd's the ultimate old man he's
he's he's always gonna be able to on
this team you know he's a goddess
does everything the right way hold
everybody accountable and really a guy
look to to you know try to emulate and
be a pro you know I mean I haven't
really talked to him about it but you
know at the end of the day was most
important to all of us is when involved
you know what I mean it I know he's
gonna do whatever he can you know help
Baker and prepare Baker give him some
wisdom and just you know knowledge of
the game you know cuz he's assess and
you know I think that having having true
anti-rock with Baker you know especially
Drew's history you know with the
quarterbacks he had under him
I think it'll definitely be tremendous
for Baker and uh you know we can't wait
to go out there and play play play hard
for more decent you know when you have a
rookie quarterback you know that's just
that's the job with your defense to take
care of them you know take the ball away
put them on the shortest possible field
you know especially me as a returning to
a defense of God I'm still looking to
try to get the best possible field
position I can get for them you know
things like that so we understand that
you know tie-rod understands and you
know we're all in this thing together
system one ball game I gotta be honest
with you Jabril I mean whenever the I
mentioned the Browns among
my friends or I mentioned the Browns
anywhere essentially everybody mentions
one in 31 and it sounds to me through
you that that page has been turned
Mayfield is the latest one to turn that
page in that locker room on that
absolutely no you can't you can't always
you know live in the past you know we we
we know what our record is over the
years but as far as I'm concerned we're
one one and one and these people were
worse records than that right now all
that matters is right now man we have
another opportunity to go out there gets
a good rate of team and no stack another
one you know that's where I focus it
everyone can say what they want to say
but at the end of the day you got to put
that ball down the line up again okay
and I looked to you sir
University of Michigan great which you
are how does the Michigan fanbase watch
Ohio State Penn State how are you gonna
watch that what what should the Michigan
fanbase do for these two teams watching
this one do you have any any advice you
know I don't really have any advice on
that but I know you know when I was in
when I was in college you know I look
forward to you know watching those games
to see how you know they fared against
one another especially if we played one
already or you know we where we're up
and coming about to play them so it's
always good to you know see how they do
against no good competition
yeah we'll what do you think last one
for you what do you think of the
Michigan start so far this year you know
I started off a little slow against you
know Notre Dame but you know new new
quarterback you know pry some some
jitters
you know guys out there you know plan
for the first time and some guys who've
had some uh some some experience but
going up there to South Bend you know
and the night game was tough environment
well you know you still got to go out
there put your best foot forward to come
out on top
so besides that and plus you never want
to lose another game or you know any of
those guys so besides that man I think
they're doing you know I think they're
doing a great job finding funding our
identity
finding their swagger no Gaza
scoring points and lots of it you know
you got DPJ making plays on often his
end and in the return game you know he
already has more than me oh yeah too
late now so you know if he keeps you
know taking home one balls back like
that you know that that does a lot for
you know team around and momentum so you
know they just beat up on a big tempo
and I'm looking forward to the next
Jabril I appreciate the call way to
fight through the hiccups way to get it
done way to focus thanks for the call
right back at you that's your broken
purse so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience